The shocking end of Fantastic Beasts: The
Crimes of Grindelwald has left many fans scratching
their heads as to what it really means and
how it ties in with the Harry Potter movies.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'm breaking down all the
details in the twist ending to Fantastic Beasts
2 and explaining why you can't trust Grindelwald!
Keep watching to the end to find out what
crucial timeline details have been retconned
in the sequel.
And to celebrate the release of a new Fantastic
Beasts movie, I'm giving away an amazing set
of official movie merchandise, including a
very cool set of Nifflers.
Tap the Gleam link in the video description
to enter the giveaway.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care if
you haven't seen the movie yet.
In Fantastic Beasts 2, Credence goes on a
quest to discover his true identity and after
chasing down a red herring that he's Leta
Lestrange's brother Corvus, in the final scene
Grindelwald tells the young wizard that his
true identity is Aurelius Dumbledore.
To support this revelation Grindelwald takes
the baby chick that Credence has been taking
care of and it transforms into a phoenix.
Potter fans will know that phoenixes are associated
with the Dumbledore family and Fawkes was
a phoenix who was a companion and protector
to Albus Dumbledore at Hogwarts.
This reveal about Credence has shocked Potter
fans as until now the character Aurelius Dumbledore
has never appeared or been mentioned in any
movies or books, which is strange given Grindelwald
predicts that he and Aurelius will "together
go down in history as [they] remake this world."
During the reveal, Grindelwald also tells
Credence that his "brother seeks to destroy"
him, implying that Dumbledore plans to kill
Credence.
This patently isn't true as during the movie,
it was Albus who asked Newt to go to Paris
and try to save Credence.
In fact, J.K.
Rowling herself said in an in an official
featurette released for the film that "whatever
you think you know at the end of the movie
might not be the case."
So, let's go through all the evidence as to
why Grindelwald could very well be lying.
Much is made in the movie about what a master
of persuasion and deception Grindelwald really
is.
Right at the beginning, President Picquery
remarks that they had to cut out the nefarious
wizard's tongue and change his guard three
times because he's so persuasive.
Little did she know that Grindelwald had actually
recruited Abernathy to his cause and switched
places with him, and Abernathy ends up rewarded
with a forked tongue of his own.
In Paris, Grindelwald recruits the bounty
hunter Grimmson who is supposed to be hunting
down Credence.
He also recruits a huge number of wizards
to his cause in the speech he gives at the
end, and he even tricks the sweet-natured
Queenie over to his side, which I'll talk
more about later.
In fact, it feels like Grindelwald is more
than just persuasive; he's actually the man
behind the curtain, a puppet master pulling
on everyone's strings and bamboozling everyone
with red herrings and tricks, all for his
own nefarious ends.
For example, when Credence goes to find the
nanny who'd looked after him, the bounty hunter
Grimmson kills her on Grindelwald's orders.
It seems like Grindelwald wanted rid of her
to clear up any loose ends and true answers
she might provide to Credence.
Grindelwald also had the Lestrange family
history moved from the French Ministry archives
to the Lestrange mausoleum.
Which raises questions as to why he did that
and what information he might have manipulated.
After that scene, Newt points out to Tina
that all these things including "Queenie,
the family tree, it's all been bait" to get
them to the rally that Grindelwald is holding.
And you can see during Grindelwald's speech
to the wizarding community that he's very
skilled in rhetoric and manages to convince
many people.
He knows how to make his extreme positions
and views sound almost reasonable and sensible
to them.
Director David Yates has said that Grindelwald
is quite different to the other big bad we
all know from the Harry Potter series, Voldemort.
Yates says, "If you disagreed with Voldemort,
he would kill you in an instant.
But Grindelwald is incredibly beguiling.
He would rather win people over to his side
than annihilate them, and he is smart enough
to understand you have to win hearts and minds,
not coerce people, to gain their allegiance."
Which is why I think we can't take what he's
saying to Credence about his identity at face
value.
He knows that Credence is desperate to discover
his real identity and so he preys on that
to set Credence against Dumbledore.
He even conjures up a phoenix to bamboozle
him into believing the lie.
So, why does Grindelwald need to use Credence
against Dumbledore?
Well, in Fantastic Beasts 2 it's shown that
Dumbledore and Grindelwald were lovers when
they were younger and they made a blood pact
where they promised they would never fight
each other.
The pendant that Grindelwald wears and which
Newt's niffler steals from him contains drops
of blood from the two wizards and the actual
existence of the pendant seems to physically
prevent Dumbledore and Grindelwald from attacking
each other directly.
At the end of the movie, Newt gives the pendant
to Dumbledore who indicates he will look into
whether he can destroy it.
Part of me wonders if Dumbledore seems a little
reluctant to break the blood pact and whether
he's holding out hope he can turn his old
friend away from the dark path he's chosen.
The other major reason that Grindelwald needs
Credence is because of his immense power as
an Obscurial.
Normally, an Obscurus would have killed its
host by the age of ten but Credence has survived
into adulthood demonstrating his superior
wizarding powers.
And in Fantastic Beasts 2, by the end of the
movie we finally see that Credence has gained
control over his power.
Grindelwald gives him a wand and Credence
uses it to blast away the side of a huge mountain
in the distance.
This is in stark contrast to the first movie
where Credence explicitly said he didn't want
to control his power:
"You can control it.
Credence."
"I don't think I want to, Mr. Graves."
Now that Grindelwald has manoeuvred Credence
to his side and he's been able to focus the
young wizard's rage, he will presumably use
him as a weapon against Dumbledore next.
Credence is perhaps one of a few wizards powerful
and foolhardy enough to confront Dumbledore
as remember how earlier in the movie when
Grindelwald asked his followers if they would
go to Hogwarts and attack Dumbledore, not
one of them said they would.
What's interesting about Credence's identity
is that it's changed in every film so far,
meaning it wouldn't surprise me if we discover
Credence's true family line in the next Fantastic
Beasts movie.
He might be connected to an alternate character
from Potter lore.
After all, we see he's good friends with Nagini
who will end up eventually as Voldemort's
snake, so could there be a connection between
Credence and Voldemort?
Let me know what you think.
Another victim of Grindelwald's manipulations
in Fantastic Beasts 2 is Queenie who ends
up becoming a follower of the dark wizard.
Although I felt her turn to the dark side
was a little abrupt, you can see why she personally
feels attracted to the idea of overturning
the restrictive laws which forbid her from
having an open relationship with muggle Jacob.
I do wonder whether any foul play was at work
though.
After all, there was that teapot which kept
trying to serve her more tea.
So, I wonder whether anything was slipped
into her drink to make her more susceptible
to Grindelwald's guile.
There's been quite a bit of discussion in
the fandom that the timeline for Credence
being Albus Dumbledore's brother is also problematic.
The main issue people have identified is that
when the first Fantastic Beasts movie came
out in 2016, Ezra Miller said in an interview
that Credence was 18 years old in that film.
Fantastic Beasts And Where To Find Them was
set in 1926 which would have made his birthday
sometime in 1908 or 1907.
And that just doesn't fit very well with the
fact that the books established that Albus
Dumbledore's mother Kendra died in 1899, many
years before Credence's supposed birthdate.
However, some new evidence just came out via
the original screenplay for The Crimes of
Grindlewald which indicates that the shipwreck
scene happens in 1901.
In that scene, Leta Lestrange swapped Credence
with her brother Corvus just before the ship
sunk meaning Credence was a baby in 1901 and
therefore his birth date, say a couple of
years earlier, would fit roughly with the
year 1899 that Kendra Dumbledore died.
Now, that still doesn't mean that Credence
is definitely a Dumbledore, it's just that
some retconning seems to have happened for
Fantastic Beasts 2 to make Credence's age
line up with the Dumbledore reveal.
So, do you think Grindelwald is lying to Credence
at the end of Fantastic Beasts 2?
And if you do, who do you think Credence really
is?
I've added a poll where you can vote – just
tap in the top right of this video and after
you've cast your vote you'll be able to see
the results.
Let me know what you think in the comments
below and remember to click on the gleam link
in the video description for a chance to win
a cool Fantastic Beasts merch pack.
Tap left for another theory and ending explained
video or tap right for another video you're
sure to like!
And if you enjoyed this, remember to subscribe
and leave a thumbs-up for more videos like
this.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!